اهدنا الصراط المستقي
م من حبهم له وتقديرهم لعظم شانه بين
الشهور يلقب المغاربه الشهر المبارك
بسيدنا رمضان فقبل ان يهل هلاله يباركون
لبعضهم بعضا بالعباره الشهيره مبروك
عواشرك والتي يقصد بها عشرات شهر الصوم
الثلاث الثلاث عشر الرحمه وعشر المغفره
وعشر العتق من النار تبدا الاستعدادات في
بلاد المغرب في اواخر شعبان بتنظيف
المساجد والبيوت لتكون في ابها حله وتقتني
النساء اواني خاصه لا تستعمل الا خلال هذا
الشهر الفضيل وفي المغرب لا تتزين المساجد
والبيوت فقط بل سكانها ايضا بارتداء اجمل
الملابس التقليديه خلال الزيارات العائليه
او عند الذهاب الى المسجد او العمل يحرص
المغاربه على خياطه او اقتناء الجلابه او
الجبادور او الكندوره ويكتمل اللباس
التقليدي المغربي بنعل من الجلد يسمى
البلغاء وفي رمضان يوحد الحرير الموائد
المغربيه والحريره حساء من قطع اللحم
والطماطم والبقوليات كالحمص والعدس كما
تتزين المائده المغربيه بانواع من
المخبوزات كالمسمن والبغرير والمملحات
كالبسطيله والبريوات ولا تكتمل مائده
رمضان في المغرب بدون حلوى الشباكيه وسلو
التي ترافق اتاي او الشاي المغربيه
بالنعناع
يحرص المغاربه على تدريب اطفالهم على
الصيام ويتدرجون في تنميه قدراتهم عليه
وفق ما يعرف بتخياط انهار حيث يصوم الطفل
نصف يوم ويفطر ثم يصوم نصف اليوم التالي
ليتم صيام يوم كامل وتحتفي الاسر المغربيه
باطفالها الصائمين بطريقه مميزه خاصه في
ليله القدر حيث ترتدي الفتيات التكشيطه او
القفطان وتزين ايديهن بالحناء ويوضع على
رؤوسهن تاج تقليدي
وتحملن على العماريه فيما يرتدي
الفتيانوزيا تقليديه ويركبون على حصان
مشرج
ولا يحلو رمضان في المغرب دون جولات
النفار التي تكسر سكون الليالي يمر النفار
في جوف الليل بين الازقه نافخا في مزماره
منبها الى مواقيت السحور
[موسيقى]
يتميز شهر رمضان في المغرب باقبال كبير
على صلاه التراويح وتغص المساجد وباحاتها
بالمصلين ما يعكس مكانه هذا الشهر الفضيل
في نفوس المغاربه
[موسيقى]